On the 6th of July, the official Elden
Ring website was updated with a new
description. It reads as follows:
The Golden Order has been shattered.
Throughout the Lands Between, Demigods holding
shards of the Elden Ring squabble and make war
over the ruins of a perfect realm, now abandoned
by the golden guidance of the Greater Will.
As the echoes of this conflict thunder in
the distance, an outcast arrives. Once,
their ancestors called the Lands Between home,
but the blessed light of grace was lost to
their tribe long ago, and they were expelled
from the kingdom. They are the Tarnished,
and they have returned to claim the Elden
Lordship promised to them by legend.
Those few inhabitants who are not mad or hostile linger near the broken remnants
of cities left behind by the Shattering. They may
have answers for you, if you help them. Above them
all, ensconced in legacies bristling with traps,
secrets, and guardians, the Demigods - warped
Lords who began as members of a royal and noble
family - rule their domains with the unyielding
power granted by shards of the Elden Ring.
This is probably all the story we're going to get
until Gamescom at the end of August, and combined
with everything else, it's actually a ton to go
over, so I've shattered it all into 8 sections.
Let's get into it, starting with
the character they're building up
as the big boss of Elden Ring.
Her name is Queen Marika, the Eternal.
She's first mentioned on the official site, which
reads "In the Lands Between ruled by Queen Marika
the Eternal, the Elden Ring, the source of the
Erdtree, has been shattered. Marika's offspring,
demigods all, claimed the shards of the Elden Ring
known as the Great Runes, and the mad taint of
their newfound strength triggered a war.
The Japanese word they use for "Eternal"
is the same one used to describe the
"perpetuity" of the Everlasting Dragons,
so she likely has a sort of immortality, like
them. Her offspring are demigods, after all, so
it would make sense that she's a sort of deity.
Now, it is still possible that Marika is innocent
in all of this, and that her offspring alone
are responsible for the shattering. That said,
a Russian site calls her the "mistress of the
coveted ring", which I think suggests she has
claimed at least some of it's power...and assuming
she's still the ruler of the Lands Between,
it is at least being implied
that she has benefited from,
and played a part in, the ring's shattering.
From what we can tell, the reasons for shattering
the Elden Ring so far are
a) to claim its power, but also
b) to upset the world order and inspire chaos.
Because despite Marika "ruling" the Lands Between,
her demigod offspring are actually squabbling
with one another, and "making war". According
to an interview with Miyazaki, each demigod
can be found at the end of Legacy dungeons,
and since there is one legacy dungeon per open
world, that means each demigod likely has a
chunk of the open world under their dominion.
This sort of drama between kingdoms is part
and parcel of George R. R. Martin's writing, and
since we're expected to "delve into the complex,
bloody history of the Shattering", I expect
there to be a ton of lore behind each demigod.
A large part of the designs of these these
major characters will be how they were twisted
by claiming shards of the Elden Ring. According
to Miyazaki, "they each inherited a different
power or element, so to speak, and each
was twisted and warped in its own way,
and it brought a tainted strength to each of
them. They each fell to madness and fell to ruin
in their own individual ways. So while there
is heroic and mythological elements to them,
they are also going to have this very mad
taint and this deep-seated ruin to them."
And it seems like one such lord has already
been revealed to us. This heavily armed boss
is referenced in a tweet from June 24th, which
reads "A lord clings to his ruined legacy; the
ruler of a husk wrung dry by war". While I guess
it's possible he's a lord from the world before
the shattering clinging to his ruined legacy,
it's still more likely that he's a demigod,
since he's a perfect example of a character that
might be tainted and ruined by the Elden Ring.
And you have to wonder..did any of them, including
Marika, expect the Elden Ring to twist and taint
them in such a way? Do they even care?
According to the official site, the shards of
the Elden Ring are called "Great runes". Runes
are simply a type of alphabet, but in fantasy
writing they're often used as words of magical
power. Together, it seems, these runes "spell",
the Elden Ring..but since the Elden Ring has been
shattered, alone, some of these runes have been
claimed. A long, long time ago, the earliest
leak about Elden Ring actually revealed the game
was once called "Great Rune", said to be a game
about travelling to distant kingdoms and claiming
the power that lies there. Therefore, I wonder if
defeating a demigod might allow you to claim their
power in some way, perhaps getting a specific
ability or powerup? Accroding to the trailer,
the Elden Ring IS a weapon, after all..
Brandish the Elden Ring..
For all of us.
They've done an excellent job with the
concept of the Elden Ring, because even though we
know so much about it, it's still hard to pin down
exactly what it is. It's made up of runes, making
it literal..it gives order to the world, making
it seem conceptual..and yet it's also so physical,
able to be hammered and shattered into pieces.
One wonderful discovery is how similar
the shattering scene with the blacksmith
is to this "forging of the ring" concept art by
Alan Lee, who has done a lot of official artwork
for Tolkien's "Lord of the Rings" series. Like
the "One Ring", the Elden Ring also has text
upon it..it's also a weapon of great power,
and perhaps most importantly - it also has
a will associated with it.
According to the official site,
when the demigods triggered the "Shattering"
war, they were abandoned by the "Greater Will".
Somehow, this "Greater Will" persists despite the
ring being shattered, and has decided that these
demigods, once members of a royal and noble
family, are no longer worthy of its favor.
Instead, it seems, this favor has been
returned to us instead: the Tarnished.
"And now the guidance of grace will be brought
to the Tarnished who were spurned by the grace
of gold and exiled from the Lands Between."
According to Miyazaki, "you could call them
tarnished individuals who have lost grace. And
this was a long time preceding the setting of
the game, a long time before. The ancestors of
the characters that are present in the world were
banished and exiled from The Lands Between, these
Tarnished. Then a long time after that, the Elden
Ring was shattered in a historical event. This
triggers the return of this lost grace and it
calls out to the Tarnished, who were once exiled
from The Lands Between, and it guides them back.
So this is the starting point, or the impetus for
the game itself, the Tarnished being called by the
lost grace and returning to The Lands Between"
The Tarnished are a lot like the Unkindled of
Dark Souls 3, in the sense that they
were deemed unworthy a long time ago,
but now are being called back..almost as a
last resort. It's a chance to redeem ourselves,
but don't you guys also think it feels kind
of insulting? Like.."oh, now you need us!",
you know? Miyazaki goes on to say "I feel like one
of the main themes of the game is how the player,
the Tarnished, approaches or treats this new-found
grace and this return to the land that they were
once banished from, how they interpret this and
the meaning. It's not just the player-character,
of course, it's lots of characters in the game,
who are all beckoned back and will have their
own adventures and motives. We want the player
to discover for themselves what that means and
how they want to begin their adventure."
In Dark Souls 3, we stood before the Soul
of Cinder itself, and have the choice to take
its place and restore the current world order.
As Unkindled Ash, this was our logical goal..but
after seeing what happened to all the other Lords
of Cinder, you realise being a Lord of Cinder
is a sacrificial, subservient role. Similarly,
the goal for our Tarnished is to stand before
the Elden Ring, and become an "Elden Lord",
and while that sounds like a real power fantasy
title..I'm sure the reality won't be as great
as it sounds. The shards of the Elden Ring have
twisted the demigods, after all..imagine what
its full power might do to us, as Tarnished.
And the word "Tarnished" is such a wonderful term
for these characters, because when a metal
is tarnished, it means it's lost its luster.
Similarly, we have lost our "golden grace".
Specifically, this golden light was once found
in our eyes. Miyazaki says: "The Lands Between
are blessed by the presence of the Elden Ring
and by the Erdtree, which symbolizes its presence,
and this has given grace or blessing to the people
throughout the land, great and small. What this
represented in them is this sort of golden light,
or this golden aura, that's specifically shown in
their eyes. And this symbolizes the blessing or
the grace of the Erdtree. However, after a time,
there were some individuals who lost this grace,
and the light faded from their eyes. And
these are what are known as the Tarnished"
If this boss is indeed a demigod,
then unsurprisingly, he no longer has
golden eyes. Interesting then, that he speaks down
to us Lowly Tarnished..it's like..man, I don't see
any golden grace in your eyes, either! So whatever
sin the Tarnished committed ages ago must set us
apart. For even though we've apparently regained
some of our grace, the golden light doesn't seem
to have returned to our eyes..and all we've been
able to do, is return to the Lands Between.
To get to the Lands between, you apparently
have to first traverse The Foggy Sea. Since
we know the Lands Between are an open world and
that that's where most of the game takes place,
I bet traversing the Sea of Fog is a sort
of tutorial. Developers have to control your
experience at the start to teach you the ropes,
like the Journey to the Nexus in Demon's Souls, or
escaping from the Asylum in Dark Souls. Once
you're out, you're on your own, and free to
go and die in the catacombs, so to speak.
The Lands Between, or the "Riftlands" as they've
been called, are the "ruins of a perfect
realm", now ruled by Queen Marika.
Remember the "Things Betwixt" area at the start
of Dark Souls 2? It uses the same Japanese word
that roughly translates to "Interspace" in
its name..and so does the Lands Between,
so maybe these places are comparable in some way.
The question is: the lands between..what? Above,
obviously, is the higher plane marked
by the light beyond the Erdtree..but
then what is below? Earth? Hell? We are
considered "dead" beings, after all..maybe that's
what's behind the sea of fog. Alternatively, there
are a lot of spirits in the Lands Between..like
our horse..maybe the Lands Between is a world
where creatures have one foot in the mortal realm,
and one in the divine. Hard to say for sure.
At any rate, these Lands Between are intertwined,
and appear to be layered on top of one another
around the Erdtree. Proof of this is seen in this
snowy world, where we are significantly closer
to the top of the tree than in the other scenes,
where you could even see higher planes in the
distance. According to this tweet from June 15th,
"our path reaches up to the
branches of the heavens,
and twists down into the roots of the earth".
I love the order to all of these concepts..
Starting at the top, there is the Greater Will
- which sounds akin to a god, capable of being
incredibly benevolent, blessing the land, and
incredibly vindictive, exiling those who displease
it. It is probably responsible for the Golden
Order for the world, the Japanese word for which
translates to "Commandment" or "Law". For lack of
a better word, the Greater Will is "aligned" with
the Elden Ring, as it has clearly taken offense
to its shattering. The Elden Ring is "at the
heart" of the Erdtree, and pure light filters
down from behind its branches: called "guidance
of grace" and "grace of gold". It manifests upon
the Lands Between as pockets of lost grace, which
act as checkpoints to guide the player..and
manifests within characters as golden eyes.
Now, originally, I thought our character was
marked as a Tarnished by their grey hair,
but in my comments, Bandai Namco clarified
that "In the Lands Between, a Tarnished is not
marked by a loss of the color red, but of another
color". Now we know that color is gold...but the
question remains: who are the red haired race of
beings? Namely, This giant, and this valkyrie?
The big war we know about is the Shattering War,
and I'd bet that's what we're witnessing here,
because of this scene, where a soldier
strikes this giant at the same time we're
presented with the ring shattering.
Therefore, you'd think the red haired race
would be enemies of the demigods like we are..so
why then, does the valkyrie impale us? Is the sin
Tarnished ancestors committed ages ago so terrible
that they're hated by literally everyone?
This is a random note, but in the last video I
thought you could see a bit of red inside the new
firekeeper's hood..however, there's been a bit
of debate on the reddit regarding whether it's
actually red, or a trick of the light, since it
appears more golden here. It would certainly be
interesting if she was one of the red haired
race, but we'll have to wait and see.
Speaking of red haired characters, one of my
favourite fantasy stories of all time is "The Name
of the Wind" by Patrick Rothfuss, and it features
a protagonist known for his fiery hair. Okay,
he's known for more than that..let me pull up this
excerpt from Audible, and let him explain.
I have stolen princesses back from sleeping
barrow kings. I burned down the town of Trebon.
I have spent the night with Felurian
and left with both my sanity and my
life. I was expelled from the University at a
younger age than most people are allowed in.
I tread paths by moonlight that
others fear to speak of during day.
I have talked to Gods, loved women, and
written songs that make the minstrels weep.
You may have heard of me.”
This is an audiobook you can listen to for free,
during your 30-day Audible trial. So go and
visit Audible dot com slash vaatividya or text
vaatividya to five hundred five hundred,
to start your free trial right now.
The Name of the Wind is a three-part series..and
it seems like the third novel might never come
out at this point..but hey, that makes it a
perfect recommendation for Elden Ring fans right!
I know how much you guys love waiting... Seriously
though, the author is fantastic at intriguing the
reader with all sorts of questions about
the story, while also hiding their answers
all throughout the series..kind of like what
Souls does, honestly. It's one of my favourite
stories to date, and I know a lot of people in
the comments can vouch for that as well..
So again, go and visit Audible dot com
slash vaatividya or text vaatividya to
five hundred five hundred, to get started today.
Thank you, to Audible, for sponsoring this video..